the working title of Star Wars Episode
eight has been revealed and it's
interesting I'm Kate and this is your
GameSpot news update while it will be
some time before we learn of the film's
official name we now know that Star Wars
Episode 8 has a temporary title of space
fare Carrie Fisher revealed all when she
posted this picture to Twitter space
fare follows in the tradition of strange
titles for other Star Wars films during
production the force awakens was known
as foodies while it was shooting and
Return of the Jedi was famously filmed
under the title of blue harvest
principal photography on Episode eight
officially began last week the news was
revealed by a short video that showed
director Ian Johnson on set with Styles
Daisy Ridley and Mark Hamill it was also
announced that sicarios Benicio del Toro
and Jurassic Park star Laura Dern had
joined the cast the movie is currently
shooting in London and will then move to
Croatia for location work according to
making Star Wars the Croatian shoot will
make use of drones and 600 guards to
ensure that the production is kept
hidden from the public
so what do you think space bear means is
it a huge hint at Chuy's involvement a
possible Ewok comeback or just a
meaningless working title let me know in
the comments I'll come and find me on
Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it GameSpot